Okay Michael, so I would like to give you a quick quiz.
>> Thanks.
>> You're welcome, Michael. I'm about helping others. Okay, so
here's the problem. Let me set it up for you.
You let me know if the, if, if the question
doesn't make any sense. Okay, so we have a set of
fea, we have a problem, we have a learning problem
that has four features in the input space, and I'm labeling
them a, b, c, and d. And here's a table
that has some training data. You'll notice that it's all binary,
I'm representing the binary as zeroes and ones
here, and that's the space that they're in. And
I have a label, minus or plus, which you
could also think of as zeroes and ones. Okay?
>> Okay.
>> And, here's what I want you to do. I want
you to find the smallest subset of features of a, b,
c, and d, that's sufficient to get zero training error, for
these two different learning algorithms, decision trees, the first one, and
the second is perceptron, but a very simple perceptron
where you simply have w transpose x greater than
zero. If it's greater than zero, you return positive.
If it's zero or less, you return negative. Got it?
>> I think so, yeah.
>> Okay, and so what I have out here are a bunch of checkboxes and I want you
to check off the variables that you need, or
the features that you need, in order to allow decision
tree to get zero training error or to
allow the simple perceptron to get zero training error.
>> And are we supposed to do this thinking of
it as a filtering thing or a wrapping thing, or?
>> Yes.
>> I see, so you just want to ans, us to answer the question.
>> yes. I want to answer the question and as a hint,
you should be thinking about this as a filtering or wrapping problem.
>> [LAUGH] I was kind of hoping you would tell me
which of those two.
>> Well let's see, you were really good
at picking filtering, so think about it as filtering.
>> Oh, okay.
>> So, so, I'm not going to ask you, I'm not going to require as a part
of the quiz, that you tell me
what criterion you were using, information gain, or
entropy, or variance, or anything like that,
but when you give me the answer, I'm
going to ask you to explain it to
me, because I'm curious what you're thinking, okay?
>> Okay, but I'm allowed to use the label to answer it too?
>> Yes, you're allowed to use the label if you want to, if you
think it's necessary.
>> Right, because filtering methods, I, well I guess you
said that they, they can have access to the label.
>> Yes.
>> Okay.
>> You got it?
>> I think so, yeah, yeah.
>> Alright, good. Okay, okay. Well so, go.